هذه المحطه في خيرسون جنوب اوكرانيا كانت
هدفا لضربات روسيه جديده مساء الثلاثاء
القصف حصل في وقت كان فيه اكثر من 100
مدني ينتظرون اجلائهم
انه يوما صعب من الاكيد كان هناك العديد
من المدنيين سيتم توفير جميع المعلومات من
طرف الجهات
المعنيه في جبهات اخرى تستمر المعارك
مدينه مارينكا الواقعه في منطقه دونيتس
جنوب شرق اوكرانيا تحولت الى انقاض وزير
الدفاع الروسي اكد الاثنين ان قوات بلاده
سيطرت عليها القائد العام للجيش الاوكراني
الذي عقد مؤتمرا صحفيا لاول مره منذ بدايه
الحرب اشار الى تراجع الجيش الاوكراني الى
مشارف
مارينكا مارينكا قاومت لمده عامين تقريبا
في كل شارع وفي كل منزل وحتى يومنا هذا
قواتنا في الجزء الشمالي منها لقد اعدوا
خط دفاع خارج المدينه لكن يمكنني القول ان
هذه المدينه لم تعد
موجوده الجيش الاوكراني لا يحقق تقدما في
هجومه المضاد لكنه حقق نجاحات اخرى قليله
منها ضرب سفينه روسيه في شبه جزيره القرم
الثلاثاء يشتبه في انها تحمل طائرات مسيره
ايرانيه تستخدمها موسكو في حربها ضد كيف
هجوم اكده
الكريملين